lorsque vous voyez sont des images du
vidéoclip de sarah may qui a été nommé à
d'ailleurs aux juno comme vidéoclip de
l'année est avec nous ce matin parce que
le grand public est invité à célébrer la
culture noire à travers de nombreuses
activités sociales culturelles dans
différents lieux de montréal et c'est
donc la 29e édition sahara mais bonjour
vous êtes la porte parole du mois de
l'histoire des noirs pourquoi vous avez
accepté d'être porte-parole
mais tout d'abord je fais partie de la
communauté inévitablement puis je pense
que c'est un bon mois pour célébrer ce
qui se passe dans la culture noire
ces artisans les gens qui en font partie
et qui contribue à la société québécoise
c'est un mois pour s'ouvrir pour
communiquer c'est vraiment très
rassembleur en fait et voilà on veut
sensibiliser les gens aux enjeux aussi
des fois qu'il ya au niveau économique
et sociaux donc voilà je suis fier pour
la thématique c'est ici et maintenant
vous voulez vous adresser davantage à la
jeunesse je crois tout à fait et s'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes lauréats cette année
à 12 jeunes l'horaire que ce soit en
politique au niveau social qui sont
impliqués dans la communauté et donc
real parce qu'il y aura un gala jouit
tout à fait moi il ya le gala dynastie
qui aura lieu le 1er mars donc à la
place des arts donc chinaud mais
également dans ce cas là mais ça
récompense tout le monde de la
communauté au niveau sportif social
musical donc c'est ça va être vraiment
intéressant c'est bizarre mais on a vu
des images de votre vidéo clip qui a été
tourné au sénégal oui ça s'apprend tout
une dimension particulière j'imagine
dénommé aussi aux juno 1 grâce à ce
tournage l'a vraiment amusés
commençaient un clip qui me tient
beaucoup à coeur et la réalisatrice
carraz lorsqu'elle m'a proposé un
scénario là pour le clip j'étais
vraiment touché parce que je suis très
connecté avec le sénégal j'essaye d'y
aller plus souvent possible et que c'est
un clip qui met l'emphase sur la femme
en général la femme africaine mais toute
la résilience la force et que là ça
tombe le mois des noirs et qu'on soit
nominé au genoa
oui voilà et la consécration le travail
qui a été fait un vidéoclip qui
s'appelle bonne ben oui c'est un danger
regorge américain c'est ça qu'est ce que
ça veut dire brûlés en traduction en
français mais c'est plutôt brûler les
standards pour brûler les stéréotypes
est soi-même s'accepter c'est vraiment
une chanson qui qui rejette toute
conformité et puis qui essayent qui
envoie le message de ces mai puis de
s'accepter tel qu'on est en fait c'est
ce que vous avez construit aussi comme
comme identité à travers un mélange
musical les origines les langues
ouais en fait c'est ça j'ai grandi en
afrique ici j'ai côtoyé plusieurs
cultures et ça se reflète dans la
musique de plus en plus et je pense avec
l'âge et le temps j'ai le goût de parler
d'eux c'est différent je pense qu'ils
qui doivent fait mon mini cités et qui
me permet d'être dans la société et puis
de dettes ouverte à certaines choses
est-ce que vous portez un regard quand
même critique de l'état des choses pour
la communauté noire est ici au canada
c'est sûr c'est sûr il se passe plein de
choses parfois qui ternissent qui
peuvent ternir espaces parfois des
choses malheureuses mais je pense que
plusieurs personnes font de société donc
faut que chacun mène sa part et qu'on
change un petit peu je pense que des
changements qui s'opèrent en ce moment
beaucoup dans le monde à plusieurs
niveaux et forrest et conscientiser et
puis parler quand il le faut qu'est ce
qui vous touche le plus personnellement
- la justice
c'est sûr que le racisme la haine tout
ce qu'ils voient là toute cette
négativité là moi ça me touche je pense
que il faut apprendre à s'ouvrir si on
reste dans l'inconnu on ne peut pas
apprendre à connaître d'autres personnes
donc c'est un moment pour se rapprocher
et à être conscientiser de tout le
travail qui a fait rossi d'inclusion le
travail en société oui et salué
l'évolution aussi les choses ont changé
il faut pas toujours voir le côté
négatif il ya des bons côtés et je pense
que voilà c'est un mois qu'on célèbre
depuis 29 ans mais toute l'année il se
passe des belles choses donc j'invite
tout le monde à à surveiller tout ça sur
le site internet est clair 150 activités
pour cette 29e édition six mois restants
des noirs est ce qu'il ya une activité à
laquelle vous vous les invités il y en a
plusieurs la collecte de sang d'héma
québec pour l'année me falciforme qui
est une forme d'anémié
qui est très fréquente dans la
communauté noire il n'y a pas beaucoup
de dons de sang donc on avait tous les
gens c'est le 15 février
vous pouvez voir les informations sur le
site internet ça j'y serai donc j'ai
deux étudiants et aussi à la la
conférence de webster mon collègue
rappeur sur la présence noire au québec
donc rappeur et historien webster ça va
être très intéressant et le gala
dynastie aussi mais tout plein
d'activités en dons sont musique et bien
sûr alors ça dure tout le mois de
février mais merci de nous ce matin et
puis on vous suit à la soirée des juno
merci beaucoup